Welcome, everybody, to another business Q&A
while we play League of Legends.
Super excited for another day.
Happy Thursday.
I have my usual co-host, RishyCupTV.
Rishy, welcome back.
Hey, happy Thursday, everybody.
Believe Nation.
Cup of love, you guys.
I love it.
I've got J.R.I.E.S., as usual, in the house.
Oh, I got an invite.
Trainer6 is back.
Lots to play.
These guys carried me pretty hard yesterday,
so I'm excited to have them back,
and hopefully, I can contribute something.
And then they were the wind beneath your wings yesterday.
They really were.
Nobody could see it, because the screen was frozen,
but these guys carried me hard.
I'm going to write in the chat there.
Carry me hard again today, guys, please.
All right, Rishy, what is in the cup?
Okay, today, we got a cup of cafe bustello.
What?
Cafe what?
Which, cafe bustello.
All right, butello.
Cafe con leche, have you ever had a cafe con leche in it?
Yeah.
So it's cafe con leche, basically,
and bustello is like the kind of main brand
that you can make cafe con leche at home.
I'm feeling it.
Getting my Spanish coffee on,
and today, I have a cup of excitement.
Oh, all right.
Yeah, I feel a cup of excitement
and anticipation for what is to come.
I don't know what is to come,
but I'm feeling the excitement for what is to come today.
I like it, I like it.
That's pretty good, I got my five glasses of stuff
in front of me, as usual, like coffee, water.
Is it one for each live stream today?
Yeah, maybe, I may need it, I may need it.
I got coffee that Alex brought me,
I got water, tea, vitamin water from Nina.
I better drink that first, so she's gonna get upset
in my protein stuff, so.
Amazing.
I'm ready to go.
Let's get some shout-outs before getting started.
We got Zeno back in the Twitch channel.
He wants to start another win streak.
I agree, that'd be amazing.
Although, we kind of started another win streak.
You guys didn't see it, but trainer6 and J_Ryzerise
carried me to a win streak yesterday, so.
I love it, I love it.
Well.
Awesome.
What are we gonna lead off with?
What's our first question?
Okay, first question comes today from Jennifer.
And Jennifer says, at the moment,
I would kindly ask you to advise me
on the type of business I should begin
in terms of a plan.
That's it.
Okay.
So, when I first got this question,
I was like, aw, Jennifer, I wanna know more.
You know, you have this opportunity to ask Evan
for some valuable feedback and you want to know,
you know, advice for your business
and a plan for your business,
but, you know, we don't know anything about you.
We don't know what you're passionate about.
We don't know how you wanna add value to the world.
But, I think at least what I can tell you is
that's where you need to start.
Maybe you didn't include that information
because maybe you don't know what it is
that you want to do and maybe that's a whole reason
for your question.
So, I would say start by scratching your own itch.
I think one of the best ways to think about
what business do you wanna start is
to scratch your own itch.
What is a problem in your own life
that you wish was solved?
What is something that you wish someone was providing
through a business right now
that you would pay money for to get?
And I think, you know, you may not be ready
to start today, but at least starting to get in touch
with the itch that you wanna scratch
and what do you see missing in the world?
What needs to be contributed?
Because you can begin to be that person to contribute it.
I love it.
I have a couple thoughts here.
First off, Zeno's giving us a hard time
on the Twitch livestream saying that one win
doesn't count as a streak.
So, apparently we haven't started a win streak yet.
Zeno's being rough on us, so we'll see if we can do it.
Wow.
I know, I know.
Zeno, you were all grateful earlier on today.
No, it's not good.
I like the push.
Two, Rishy, I'd also like to thank you for your support.
Two, Rishy, I'd also acknowledge what you add to the,
oh, I gotta say yes to this.
I don't wanna get kicked off.
I wanna acknowledge what you bring to the channel, too.
It's not just the opportunity to ask me a question.
It's both of us.
And, you know, I'm thinking back to the comment yesterday
that on the YouTube channel, somebody said
that you're inspiring, that your channel inspires them.
So, you know, don't discount you there.
I'm mid, I'm mid here, so you want me to play Teemo?
What do you think?
Should I do Teemo, guys?
Teemo there?
Oh, I think, yeah, let's have people,
someone else I know yesterday, I told you.
J-Rise is hovering Himer, so it means I'm gonna,
I can Teemo, it'll be fine, I'll Teemo.
And then, in terms of answering the question,
I think the worst thing that we could do
is tell you what specific business to start, you know?
Gaming is huge, so go be a gamer.
Well, maybe you don't like gaming, you know?
Maybe that's not your thing.
And the worst thing you can do is hop into an industry
just because it's hot.
J-Rise is messaging me, you want Himer?
Oh, Teemo, thanks.
The Teemo main is happening.
So to Rishy's point about figuring out what you love,
you gotta understand that you can make money
in any industry.
And you're gonna make money by being able
to help that industry, by providing value in that industry.
So what is it that is missing?
What is it that you love?
How have you helped, to Rishy's point,
scratch your own itch?
Or how have you helped other people in the past?
All of that is highly relevant and important
because it'll help make you do something that you value.
And so I'll be looking at a list of the things
that you have solved for yourself recently.
What are some problems that you've solved for yourself?
How have you overcome them?
This is something that, you know, you wake up
and what do you think about?
And then don't worry about it being the perfect plan.
Don't worry about it having to be amazing
from the start because it probably won't.
And that perfectionism holds people back from starting.
Where what you want to do is take a lot of little tests.
Like this stream is a little test, you know?
Will it become some big thing?
Maybe.
You know, it hasn't flamed out, which is good.
My morning gratitude stream on my YouTube channel
that started this week, you know?
I wanted to do it.
I said, this is an interesting idea that can help people.
So let's give it a shot.
And that seems to be working out well.
We'll see what happens if I continue it next week.
And it's a combination of like what is adding value?
Like are people coming back and are they sharing?
Are they enjoying?
And am I enjoying it too?
Do I want to keep doing it?
Do I get satisfaction from it?
And so I don't know where it's all going to go, you know?
I have a general plan,
but I don't know how it's all going to work out.
I don't know what my business is going to look like
in five years.
And some people are so attached to having the perfect plan
that they never get started.
And we're going to be taking the perfect first step.
And there is no perfect first step except for starting.
So in looking at what you love,
what problems you've solved, where your passions are,
all you need to do is figure out a way
that you can combine those in a way that helps other people.
If you can do that, if you can add value to their lives,
and you can continue to innovate,
continue to add new things in,
that's where your business is going to come from.
That's where your success is going to come from.
That's where you should focus on,
even if it doesn't make the most logical,
practical sense in the immediate future.
So awesome.
That's what I got.
Couple of things in the chat.
Looks like both Ryze and I thought
there was a tweetable moment.
Oh, all right.
You can make money in any industry.
And also trainer six said for a startup business,
to learn local SEO is a simple way to learn about the web
and you can get results.
So yeah, absolutely.
I mean, SEO is definitely going to be a huge part
of anyone who's doing any kind of online publishing.
And I think that's just as important
to be aware of that as well.
Evan, you have anything on that?
It just depends on the business.
You know, if you have a local company, SEO is important.
For Toronto Dance Salsa, local SEO is important.
For my YouTube channel, local SEO isn't as important.
SEO is important, but not so much local.
So it depends on the business and depends on your own,
like if you are not a technical person,
you don't enjoy sitting in front of a computer,
you want to go, just going to give them good luck,
have fun, and all, you want to be out talking to people,
that's where you get your energy,
then forcing yourself to do that will not be,
you'll never be great at it.
You'll get mediocre at best, you know?
If you love playing, like if your thing is baseball,
don't go play hockey,
just because people tell you that you should play hockey.
Yeah, you got to do the thing that you love.
I see you standing there alone in the game,
unless I'm on a lag, that's what I see,
standing in the middle of the game.
I'm alone, I'm alone, I'm invisible.
Timo, when you stand still, he goes invisible.
I love that.
Yeah, pretty ninja, I like the ninja.
I don't know why I keep getting mad,
again, guys, it's the least available role,
and I almost never get it, so.
Whatever, here we go, let's get some leaning fun happening.
Okay, next question comes from Sudhir,
and Sudhir, he says,
I'm about to start a teacher recruitment company.
Can you help me in getting some video resources,
or can you suggest any books for teacher recruitment?
All right, well, you know, Sudhir,
I personally don't know of some books or videos,
I'm sure, absolutely, that once you do a search on YouTube,
you will find plenty of videos.
I would look specifically into
Carney, Sando & Associates, which I know is,
I think it's the most successful global faculty,
teacher, administrative recruitment,
for specifically independent schools, at least,
it's only for independent schools.
They might be a great resource for you,
just to start either modeling, just modeling success,
we talk a lot about on the channel, modeling success,
and so if you wanna model
a successful teacher recruitment company,
I would start with Carney, Sando & Associates.
There's definitely others as well,
that's the one I'm more familiar with,
but yeah, I mean, research will go a long way
to find some books and videos,
but I personally don't have any to give you at this point.
I just died, so that's not a great start.
But JRI's got a kill, or an assist up top,
so that's definitely quality.
This guy's good, this guy's better than me,
so this is gonna be a fun show, I gotta play safe.
Well, weren't you also a teacher, Rishy?
Did I get that wrong?
Exactly, I'm actually, that's who I used
when I was being recruited, when I was in education,
and so I know a little bit about particularly
recruiters in the independent school system.
So I just know that they kind of dominate
in terms of the industry for independent schools.
So I've only had nothing but a great experience with them,
and I think they're a great place to start.
I mean, I don't know where this guy's located,
but they're global, so even if you don't,
if he's not ready to start a business,
another thing we've talked about is going to work
for someone who is already in the business,
so might be a great place to tap
into career opportunities as well.
I love it, one of our players disconnected,
so we're playing four against five,
which is never the same.
Dang it, that happened yesterday, right?
Yeah, it did happen in the first game.
We'll see, we'll see what happens.
We'll see what happens.
There's a lot of companies to model.
I would also look at just non-teacher recruitment,
like teacher recruitment maybe is pretty niche,
but a lot of the lessons from regular recruiting businesses,
you can apply to the teacher recruitment industry as well.
I don't know if it's,
if you're doing teachers,
so usually with recruitment firms,
there's high-end ones,
and there's executive recruitment centers,
and there's just regular,
and you can go all the way down to just temp workers.
Uh-oh, I'm in a fight, I'm in a fight, I'm in a fight.
Oh, I actually won that fight.
That's pretty exciting.
So I don't know what the average salary is.
I'm assuming it's probably not that high
if you're going after regular teachers.
It's not the executive teacher model,
so you can look at some of the smaller teacher
or smaller recruitment firms and see.
I would be looking at other famous entrepreneurs, too,
that you look up to,
and there's probably not going to be a fantastic
how-to manual for running a successful
teacher recruitment firm, right?
And that was the challenge that I faced
when I was starting my business.
It was a biotech software company.
It was a relatively new industry.
There weren't a lot of biotech software companies
out there that were having big success.
There wasn't a model to follow.
Oh, I got a kill!
That guy got pretty aggressive.
I'm pretty happy about that.
That's a good kill.
Good job.
I'm grateful for my first kill.
Oh, I died, no!
Out of nowhere.
Yeah, it's one of those games.
Better run.
So what I did that I found really helpful
was realize, listen, nobody's done this in the industry.
There were a few big companies,
but not a lot of info on it.
But I'm not the first guy to try to sell software before.
And that's where I looked up at Bill Gates,
and I looked at Microsoft, and I looked at McAfee,
and I looked into it, and I looked at how they got started,
zero to one, and what I could learn from that.
And I found that insanely helpful.
And so the challenge may be that,
hey, look, there's no manual
for how to run a teacher recruitment firm,
but it has been done in other industries before,
and you can learn from other recruitment agencies,
as well as just other successful entrepreneurs.
Like, I don't know who we put up,
we've got scheduled on the channel tonight,
but you can pull something from a successful entrepreneur,
anybody who's had success,
even if they're not an entrepreneur,
they're an actor, or an athlete, or a singer.
That's what I try to do on the channel,
is to be able to provide knowledge to everyone
that is applicable, regardless of what industry you're in.
So yeah, that's what I would do.
Awesome.
All right, you look like you're dominating.
I'm gonna just keep it moving.
I am not dominating.
Our team is losing.
Our team is losing, and I personally am losing too.
But it's okay.
It's okay.
We're trying.
We're coming.
We're trying to do it.
There is an interesting point in the chat
about, to your last point, just really quickly,
how you were telling the previous person
about you're gonna find success
when you do what it is that you love.
And there was an interesting example
of how this particular basketball player,
Allen Iverson, I don't know, is it Iverson?
Sure, yeah, yeah.
All the basketball fans are gonna be hanging on there.
Oh no, Iverson, yeah.
Yeah, and how he was a football player,
but his mom forced him to go into basketball.
And hey, now he's about to be inducted into the Hall of Fame.
So it's just interesting how even some people
take maybe an unplanned path,
and they somehow find success.
Do you have any comments on that kind of phenomenon?
Sure, and it would still be something that,
like, Allen Iverson, oh, nice, we got a kill.
Allen Iverson dominated.
He was one of the most dominating players
when he was still in the league.
And he's a little dude.
He may not have all the natural-born things
that you need for basketball players,
not your prototypical seven-foot center
who all you have to do is be big.
He had to hustle a lot.
And the only way you do it, he had to have,
maybe in the early days, his mom said,
go be a basketball player instead of football.
But he had to continue that.
Like, there's some point in his life
where he's not just living his mom's life anymore,
and he's off doing what he feels is right,
and that he loves.
Like, if he did not love basketball, he would have quit.
And go listen to his speech,
he's not gonna get up there and say,
yeah, you know, basketball's just okay.
Yeah, I don't really love it that much, right?
So, you know, it's okay for interest to change.
It happens, right?
Like, what you like when you're a kid
doesn't necessarily mean you're gonna still like it
later on, we evolve as people, that's fine.
But somewhere, I mean, I don't know,
I don't know Allen Iverson's story,
but I saw that guy work his face off when he was playing.
And that only happens when you love what you're doing.
Yeah, I agree, absolutely.
Listen to his speech.
I think he was already inducted,
and his speech was trending,
and I haven't seen it, but listen to his speech.
It's not gonna be talking about how great football was
all the time, and how he regrets his mom
telling him to go do it, and how much he hates basketball.
Oh my gosh, I just Googled him, and I love this guy.
Okay.
I'm sorry, I just remembered who he is now.
Go on, I'm sorry.
Why do you love him?
I saw him speak at, probably it was on Facebook.
He probably, I don't know if it was his inductment speech,
but he was like acknowledging every single one
of his children, and like, you could tell
he had just a strong value for his family
as he did for his career, and that he was just grateful
to, you know, grateful for his, it was just,
I don't know, it made me actually cry watching him,
so that was pretty amazing.
It's probably it, because he's not really known
as a speaker, at least as far as I know.
So, yeah, but don't take that, so like,
so his mom said to do something, and he did it,
and he ended up liking it, and he ended up
being really good at it.
Don't think that that's the exception, you know?
I'm sorry, don't think that that's the norm.
It is an exception, you know?
For, if you think that your mom is gonna be able
to tell you exactly what you need to do
for the rest of your life, and knows you inside out
and all the career paths you should take,
you know, sorry to your mom, but she's wrong.
You have to figure out your own path.
Like, nobody can tell you what you should be doing.
The best people can guide you, whether that's a mentor,
a coach, you know, a priest, you know, a friend.
Nobody should tell you exactly what you should be doing,
but they can guide you, they can give,
they can help you figure out your path,
because all that person sees is your life
through their eyes.
And I'm happy it worked out for him,
but don't go, it's easy to take one example
and say, oh, it worked out for him,
and then say that this is what it's gonna be for everybody.
Yep, yep, great, great advice.
All right, next question comes from
Kayati Joshi.
All right.
And he says, respected sir.
I thought of doing, yeah.
Respected sir, come on, guys, let's get in on the,
let's up the professionalism on the questions here.
Evan will be commanding that respect, okay.
I thought of doing social entrepreneurship,
so I wanted to know how it would be helpful for me.
What are the opportunities I may get in that?
Please help me.
Cool, so it sounds like Kayati Joshi
is really wanting to make a difference,
when anyone's feeling like they wanna have
that social consciousness and wanna make an impact
for the good, that's a great thing.
I still think, though, that you can't go at it
just thinking, what opportunities should I go try to find?
I think you have to start with yourself
and what's your values and who are the people
that you wanna help and who are the people
you wanna serve, and then once you are really clear,
like yesterday we had a call from the guy
who wanted to change the world and to become vegan,
so he knew exactly how he wants to make a difference.
He wanted to save the animals,
and he was really passionate about it,
so I don't think you can put the cart before the horse.
I think you have to know what it is that you wanna do
to change the world in a socially conscious way,
and then from there, as you go after opportunities,
as you kind of own the cause that you wanna be a part of.
So I wish we knew more, Kayati Joshi,
about your passions and the kind of cause
that you would wanna be a part of.
Yeah, I don't know, like I feel there's a cultural,
I wanna understand the culture a little bit better,
like obviously write into me and say esteem, sir, whatever.
So a couple things, one, I would say that
like any business should serve a social good
and not just be for profit.
You know, you need to be helping people in a process,
whatever that is, and that should make you feel good.
Right, like you can do both, it's not one or the other.
You don't have to just do, oh, there's a big fight happening.
Did I get a kill?
Yes, I got a kill, it's very sad, my team died though.
So yeah, I believe every business
should have a social angle to it
because you're helping people.
Doesn't mean you're like giving,
you don't have to give a lot away
or start a charity or anything.
You just, by the nature of what your business does,
you're helping people out.
I think of even Starbucks
and they just started a new web series,
I don't know if you saw it,
where it's, I think it was called Uprising,
Uplifting, something like that,
where it's only showing positive messages,
only showing what ordinary people are doing
to try to make a powerful difference.
And I'm excited to watch.
And Howard shows to someone I've always respected
and he's behind me on the wall,
so he's a guy that I respect
because he's built the business through values.
And sometimes you see the values
and sometimes you just want a cup of Starbucks
because they do a good job branding themselves
or you just love the taste of their coffee.
But being able to do good
and do business at the same time is important.
It's actually gonna be the topic
of our next Steve and Kelly Hangout
is doing good and being in business.
And so I'm super excited to talk about it.
And so really just, again, you could do it in any industry.
You could help in any industry.
Here I am doing gaming with Rishy,
helping answer entrepreneur questions,
what some people may consider a waste of time
in looking at previous comments
and the biases and judgments against people
who play video games.
I'm trying to add my own spin on it.
I'm trying to do my own take.
I'm trying to help the way that I can help.
Hopefully it's received.
And if not, then the market tells me that
and it doesn't work.
And then it's something, do I want to just keep doing it
because I just absolutely love it.
Part of what I love doing is having an impact.
So if the work I'm doing isn't having an impact,
I don't want to, I'm not as motivated anymore.
I don't want to keep doing this much
because I recognize my time is limited.
And I want to use it in ways that touches people.
So what opportunities are there?
The opportunities are for you to have a,
like I know he's asking it in the general sense,
but to have a big impact,
to have your life mean something to others,
to leave the world a better place and how you found it.
That's what I see is the potential impact that you can have.
And it's totally worth doing.
So it's just finding where your talents and interests
and passion all kind of line up
to make something that somebody else can't do.
Love it.
That's what I got.
Shout out to Optisourcebook.
All right.
In the chat.
And I know who that is.
I think I know who that is.
Anyway, I don't want to.
I'm still waiting for Damasta.
Who's Damasta?
I'm still waiting on that.
Can't believe we're not letting Damasta out of the box.
Damastaman.
All right.
I want to give a shout out to Trainer6
who's trying to pop everybody up in our group.
Saying this is going to be a harder game than I think,
but we can win.
So I love it.
I love it, Trainer6.
I'm doing my best to try to help out.
Fabulous.
All right.
Next question comes from Catherine.
Catherine wants to know if you recommend books
for anyone who's starting their first business.
She's a photographer and she is seeing a little profit
and steady work coming in,
but she's not sure how to get to the next level.
So do you have any books that you can recommend?
Did you say photography business?
Yeah, she's a photographer.
Got it.
So first thing is that I definitely have to recommend
Evan's video.
It's a great video.
I think it might be the first video, Evan,
that I watched on your channel.
I found you on Daryl Eade's channel.
You guys were doing a hangout
and then I immediately went to your channel
and I think this was my first video.
It's called Seven Must Read Books.
And so definitely watch that video, Catherine.
Not only is it super valuable,
but you get to see Evan speed read,
which was, I think, why I subscribed.
What, you get to see me speed read?
I saw you speed read on that video.
I don't know if you remember my comment
that was just so funny.
Anyway, it's a great video.
Oh, you know, I think it was B-roll.
Like, you don't, you just see me,
I'm talking about the book
and you just see me in the background or something, right?
Yeah, and you're scanning the book like a speed reader.
Oh, okay, okay, yeah, yeah, yeah.
So that is a great place, I think, for books.
But in terms of a book that's specifically
toward starting your first business,
Evan might have a better reference.
I just would say to you, Catherine,
that any resource that's gonna help you,
hey, I'm actually, start with Evan's one word.
What am I thinking?
There's your book, Catherine.
You've gotta get your one word, and here's why.
Because a photographer,
this photographer industry is inundated.
Like, I guess any industry, but I mean,
I mean, here in Nashville,
if you see how many photographers there are,
and one of the things that I notice
when I see all the photographers
is that they all kind of,
there's like the same way
that you see people brand themselves.
And you truly cannot tell one from the other.
I mean, you can tell that people know what they're doing,
and you can tell that people are exceptionally talented,
but I can't say that I remember seeing a brand
that like really stuck out to me
where I would know why one is any different from another.
Right.
And so the book, Your One Word,
is perfect because it talks all about,
I don't wanna say what the book says,
but it helps you tap into who you are
and how your business is on purpose.
And so differentiating your business
from someone else's is gonna be super important,
and I think that Your One Word
is the perfect place to start for that.
So yeah, differentiate your photography business
from everyone else.
All right.
Well, I always appreciate the Your One Word love there.
I do actually agree, like in any competitive business,
the finding, you wanna compete on values,
you wanna compete on what you stand for.
Most people don't even know what that is,
so that's the point of the book, I think it'll help.
While that was happening, I died again,
but our fifth player came back.
So we're now 5v5, he's way behind,
but at least we're not fighting
that four against five thing here.
So that's pretty exciting.
Photography, books, couple things that come to mind.
One, later on this afternoon, I have, whoa,
I'm being attacked here, I gotta focus.
Later on this afternoon, I have a hangout with Chase Jarvis.
He founded CreativeLive, and he's one
of the most successful photographers in the world.
So there might be some questions that we can ask him.
There's a new series that I started
on my YouTube channel called Making It,
where we look at successful people in different industries.
The first one was making it as a musician,
but we might do another one, well, we're gonna do more.
Just what is the next one, is it actor, is it photographer?
So if you're on the channel, you can leave your request
there for making it as a photographer,
and hopefully we can get some advice there, too, for you.
I think at the end of the day,
you need to find what your niche is.
I think you gotta combine it
with another passion that you have.
If you love basketball, be the photographer for basketball,
or if you love, like so many people
just fall into the typical categories.
I'm a wedding photographer,
or I'm a corporate headshot photographer,
or whatever it is, and it ends up being super boring,
and it's not what you actually want to do,
and you're competing against a lot of people,
and so what is the niche that you can carve out
for yourself that really gets you excited,
that really means something to you,
and you combine that with your value, your one word,
you're gonna be way, way, way ahead of the game,
and I'm excited for you.
That's cool, all that hangout sounds exciting today, too.
I'm really pumped about all the,
I mean, it's a lot happening today,
but I'm really pumped about them all.
Wow.
Okay.
Game's looking good there.
Yeah, we're getting better.
We're getting better.
I brought their entire team to chase me,
so it means my team can hopefully do some damage
while I'm running.
Yeah.
Watch time, yeah, going well, going well.
Next question comes from Caxon.
Caxon says, I want to add value to people's lives
when it comes to their financial wellness.
I've been having a vision on how to start teaching people
about the insurance policies for their financial wellness,
but I don't know how I can start to build momentum
in doing this.
And, I mean, it's, I can't see how I can actually do it.
So, wants to help people with financial wellness,
and wants to start teaching people about insurance policies.
Yeah, how to start building momentum.
I think any opportunity to,
I know that one thing I know about Caxon
that he included in his comment
is that he already works for a financial,
I don't think it was a bank,
but he worked for some kind of financial institution.
And how about asking if you can just start teaching,
offering a class for people right where you are
and seeing what can come of that.
You could start a YouTube channel.
I know that may not be what you're thinking
about doing in Caxon,
but that's just a great way to start adding value
to people's lives right now
without having to get anybody else's permission.
Yeah, there's just tons of ways that you could do that.
I think asking your neighbors and your friends,
what would you need help on in this particular area
of insurance policies?
Maybe starting a Facebook page
and just kind of using it as a way to research
what people need and what they're looking for.
So I don't know, those are just a few ideas.
Yeah, I love it.
I love the mission.
What I would love to see is the why behind it too.
Why is this so important to you?
What happened to you growing up that,
for most people it's a boring subject, right?
Nobody wants to talk about insurance.
It's super boring.
It's one of those things that people do
because they kind of have to,
but nobody actually really enjoys it.
So why do you enjoy it?
What is so great about it that you need to go out
and teach people about it?
What happened in your life?
Is it like you were in a bad situation
or your parents growing up or what?
There's a reason why this is so important.
So I want to know, I want that communicated to me
so that I'm connected to you better.
So that'd be my first starting point.
Then I'd be looking at how can I use my skills
to help educate?
You know, if you're just looking for speed,
the fastest way to do it is through partnerships
and alliances, so who can you connect with?
Who already has your target audience?
Who is already selling related stuff?
And how can you partner up with them?
How can you put on a seminar or webinar for their clients
and help kind of explain what you're all about
and provide value?
Do you want to be a speaker?
Do you want to have a YouTube channel?
Do you want to be in the press?
Lots of different ways to go about it.
It's really what is,
what's the best combination of your talents?
Again, if you're just looking for speed though,
the fastest way is the alliance partnerships.
The other stuff has to be a labor of love.
We've talked about YouTube a lot.
It can definitely help, but it's also not a fast thing.
A lot of work has to go into making your channel successful.
It doesn't just happen anywhere near overnight.
So if you're going to do it, then you got to figure out,
you're going to be committed to it
because you like the process of making the videos too.
So I think the storytelling part,
the why is super relevant and helpful
regardless of the path you choose.
Like if you're going to start a YouTube channel,
then I need to know the why on the channel, on the video.
If you're going to be a speaker,
I need to know the why in your story.
If you're going to do alliance partnerships,
then when you go and have that meeting,
when you're going to talk about it,
then you need to, again, have the story.
So the story is helpful in all those situations.
And then just the second part of how you go out and execute,
it's what path means to you?
What's most exciting and interesting?
Where do you want to learn?
Where do you want to apply yourself?
There's no right way.
There's just lots of different ways.
Is there anything, Evan, that you would want
in terms of, you know, if someone were to say to you,
Evan, what are your insurance policy needs?
Is there any particular value
that you would particularly be looking for personally
in terms of that you don't see out there already
or that you think maybe entrepreneurs in particular
are vulnerable to or anything like that?
Um, that's a great question.
I'm probably a typical entrepreneur.
Like, I'm so focused on going forward
that I don't really think about protecting what's behind me.
But with all of, like, so, you know,
I just recently took over trying to dance salsa.
You know, there's, I had to get insurance, right?
Like, it's just part of the business.
You need to have insurance.
Um, I like working with people
who really love their craft.
So, recognizing that I need to have a broker,
I would want to find the guy or girl
who loves what they're doing, who has the passion and energy
who, like, lives, breathes, eats, sleeps insurance
and has values that I respect
and look forward to connecting with.
And as an example, something kind of similar,
there's an entrepreneur friend of mine named Ed
who does, he hosts my website and he does data backup
and this man is obsessed with backup.
Like, I don't know, I don't, you know,
just he's obsessed with backups.
Everything has to be backed up properly.
I've never met a man so in love with backups in my life.
I just died, which is not great.
But I never wanted to be a backup expert.
That topic is so boring to me, so not interesting to me
that I would love to just give it to Ed to run with.
And I'm confident that if anything ever happens
to my files, it's backed up because Ed is on the case.
And so for the roles that I have zero interest in,
like backup, like legal, like insurance,
like actually a lot of operations,
I want people who take just massive pride in their work
and we share the same values with.
So a lot of that comes out of the story too,
explaining why you're doing it.
So that's what I would look for.
Like I want the person who loves insurance,
who just is bat crazy about insurance
to the point where, you know, obviously looking out
for my own best interests, right,
the interests of their clients.
But yeah, I don't know that there's a particular
insurance need, it's one of those things like
I trust the people around me, they tell me
I need something, I believe them,
and whatever that works out to,
then that's what I go and do.
Just kind of like unnecessary evil
than being proactively excited about insurance.
I don't know that you can get me excited about insurance,
like it's just not something I'm excited by.
Ooh, I'm under attack, but I made it out.
What about you, Rishy, I don't know,
what are you trying to, what would you want to see
from insurance?
I'm like you, Evan, I'm like, oh,
just give that to somebody else.
And it would draw me if I just had someone
who was really excited about and cared for,
like they cared for my insurance needs
like it was their own, knowing that someone cares
is always the biggest draw for me.
So if you're friendly and kind and I feel like
you really, really care about my affairs,
my business affairs, then I'm gonna probably go to you
before I go to anyone else, just because of that.
Friendly, warm interaction, so that goes a long way for me.
I love it, well, I died again,
but my team is hopefully cleaning up here.
We'll see what happens, J-Rise is on the attack.
That's, yeah, looks intense, getting intense over there.
It's pretty intense, it's pretty tense.
I have eight kills and six deaths.
That's a lot of deaths for me,
I don't usually die that often, so.
Yeah, it's good, here we go.
All right, I have a question actually
from Optisource Book, which.
Optisource Book, I think that's Sherry, is that Sherry?
I was, yes, good, I was just about to say
she's okay letting us reveal her
and I said Evan's gonna know that's Sherry.
Yeah, yeah, cool, well, welcome to Twitch, Sherry.
Yeah, so she has a question and it's kind of exciting.
She says, great, now I've lost it in the chat.
I found my one word after changing my mind so many times.
Okay.
And it's create.
Oh, okay, I like it.
It says, what do you think?
For business, I have created a solution
for saving time looking for products.
At home, I create, period.
I create a lot.
Many passions, volunteering at the park.
I help create a safe place in the woods for all.
So, sounds like create is in every area of what she does.
And I like that word, I think it's a great word.
Of course, I know that your one word
has to be something that just resonates with you.
It's really nothing that anybody can say,
yes, that's it, that's the one.
But I do think that you are on the money
when you can see how the word, it works in every context
and kind of, it can be your work,
it could be what you do with your family,
it could be what you do, it's who you are.
So, everywhere you are, that word is expressing
what you're, who you are and what you're doing in that
and any place that you go.
So, if you feel like it works with everything you do,
I think that's at least a good sign.
100%.
Hopefully what it allows you to do
is then look at what else is going on in your life
and what might be out of sync with that create.
But in terms of identifying your one word,
really what you want to start by thinking of
is what connects all the things in your life.
So, it's great that you've already
started thinking about that.
Next is going to, is this something that you've always been?
Because this isn't just like, hey, my word for the year
is create or my word for the week is create or something.
It's like it's who you've always been and always will be.
It's the constant in your life.
And so, is that the case?
And if it is, that's great.
If it's not, you may need to do some extra thinking
and maybe create is a sub, you know, sub word
or sublet of what your real one word is.
And then if you found it, then it's looking at
what areas of your life are incongruent with create.
Like, are you creating enough in your business?
Are you creating enough in your personal life?
Are you, is creative something that is being expressed
through everything that you're doing?
If I go to your website, will I feel create?
Are you attracting people who appreciate creativity?
Right, if I look at even the name, Optisourcebook,
doesn't really sound, doesn't inspire me for creativity,
but, you know, again, that's me.
It's one man's opinion.
And I ended up having to rebrand and change
my whole business around believe,
which that's when things started to really take off for me,
by the way, that's when I started to see
real momentum in my company.
And it started with the frustration
that I wasn't getting as far as I thought I should get.
So, we can't judge your one word.
Nobody can tell you what your one word should be,
or if it's a good word or bad.
It's, does it allow you to,
does it allow it to be the lens to which you see the world?
Like, if you're going to make critical decisions
in your life, can you look to the word create
and say no to a tough decision
because it doesn't let you create something?
If you're at that point, then that's the right word for you
and it can take time.
Like, again, for me, it took me a long time
to figure out what mine was.
Some people get it right away,
but that wasn't the case for me.
So, it's exciting.
Even the thought process, like,
you're already further ahead than you were before.
And so, I love it.
Yeah.
All right.
Got some water, some water battle going on right now.
Water battle?
I don't know what that means.
Well, according to me, you're in a pond.
According to what I see, at least.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, we were fighting, that's in the river.
There's a dragon there that if you kill the dragon,
it makes you extra powerful.
So, there's always these fights that occur
around the dragon because both teams want it.
Ah, okay.
Yeah.
Next question, then?
Yep.
Great.
Sophie, she's 21 years old
and she's an officer in the Israeli,
in the Israeli military.
All right.
And I absolutely hate it.
I hate the lack of freedom, the locked in cage feeling.
But I signed for the next year
and this is my parent's dream for me.
What should I do?
Keep going and finish this year for my parents
or just leave it and start looking for my passion
instead and do you think I'm a weak person if I do so?
I guess meaning if she decides to just stay
and do what her parents want and stay in the military
even though she doesn't want to,
do you think I'm a weak person?
So, hmm, wow.
You know, I had some amazing friends.
When I was in high school, I was,
I went, basically I was a part of this production
group of kids that were brought into Moscow, Russia
for this art production.
And so all the kids that were brought in,
there was like three or four from every country.
So that was the first time I met other kids my age
that were Israeli and they told me,
yeah, we have to do military service.
And I remember just seeing my mind
just being completely blown because I was so,
it was such a foreign concept that as a young person
you would have to be in the military.
So just being, I remember being struck by that
because obviously in America we don't have that reality
of, you know, that's just not our reality.
So it's interesting to me always to hear the experiences
of young people in different countries
and kind of what it is they're dealing with
and maybe interesting in the conversation
of entrepreneurship as well, just like how,
where you're from, how does that influence
just your experience?
And I don't know if I even feel at liberty to say
not to continue in the military or not
because I just feel so, for me, I don't know,
it's like, it's so far from my experience.
Like I don't even feel like I have the,
I don't feel like I have the right to say
what to do or not to do.
And maybe I'm just taking it too deeply
but I just feel like, hey,
I also feel like serviced for your country
there's like something very much
that is powerful about all of that.
So I don't know what to say about whether
you should just take off and leave
but what I can say is you're not a weak person
if you do decide to stay.
No, I don't believe you're a weak person.
I think that just the fact that you are
taking these thoughts about your future
and you are continuing to dream in a situation
that you feel like you have no options,
like those are signs of strength.
That's a sign of someone who has something in them
that is beyond their circumstances
and I don't think, I think it's just a matter of time
before that strength in you is gonna come out
and so no, you're not a weak person.
And whatever you decide to do,
you were not limited to start thinking about
what it is that you do wanna do
and in small ways every single day
taking steps toward that.
Did you die?
Yes, I did die.
Evan?
Yeah.
Aw.
It's okay, we're coming back.
We're actually winning which is great.
Oh, yes, okay.
So yeah, that's just kind of what I think
the main thing that I would want Sophie to know
is that you're not weak and even if you stay
or if you leave, you can do something every single day
toward the life that you do want.
I love it.
I think the most courageous thing you can do
is bet on yourself.
I think that's the, I think the weak thing
is doing what other people tell you to do.
Mm-hmm.
I think if you feel like it's not for you,
then you owe it to yourself to go out
and try to do something different.
Yeah, at some point in everybody's life,
you need to figure out when you're gonna start living
the life that you wanna live.
Whether you discover that early on in your life
or whether you don't figure that out until much later,
how far are you willing to go
just to make other people happy and not yourself?
I feel it's important that you,
maybe another way to think about it is
through the lens of regret that we've talked about before.
Like, are you gonna regret staying in the military?
Are you gonna regret not taking this chance
to go and bet on yourself?
Or is that gonna be a big regret for you?
Because if you will,
then you have to go and do something different.
You have to go and try something new.
I would love for everybody to get into the habit
of getting used to, if you want something,
then go out and try it
and to stop living to other people's expectations.
Like, even this, you're looking for our validation
and that what you're doing is right
and not weak.
And really, the only person that you should impress
is yourself.
J-Rise is calling me.
I went on that rant and he wants me to go through Barron's.
I'm here, I'm here, I'm here, guys.
Sorry, I was feeling love for this question.
I'd like to think that the people in my life
would support me no matter what I do.
But if they don't and I still wanna do it,
I'm not seeking their approval.
I'd love to have it, but I will not,
I don't need to have their approval for me
to go off and do the thing that I wanna do.
And I think it's a key difference.
And I think, as a parent, it's something
that I'm trying to bring down to the next generation, too,
is that I don't want, like, if Hayden wants to be a YouTuber,
that's awesome.
If he doesn't, that's awesome, you know?
Like, I love baseball, right?
Baseball, for me, growing up, was a huge thing.
You know, Hayden wanted to go to baseball camp.
We got him all the gear.
As a father, I'm, like, massively, you know,
prideful and went to coach the team and all that stuff.
And then the next year, it's like,
I don't wanna do baseball this year.
And does it hurt?
Of course, it's like, what?
Baseball, you were, it was so good.
I was coaching and, you know.
But for me to put my childhood, you know,
dreams and aspirations and what I really enjoyed
and put that on him isn't right, it's not right.
It's not the thing to do.
And so, now he's going swimming, you know?
And I'll, I have a pool in my condo and I help him swim.
And that's fun, too.
But I think it's a big problem for a lot of people
where they're just constantly having
other people's expectations put on them.
And it's not, at some point, you need to figure out
whether you're gonna live your life
or someone else's version of your life.
And hopefully, you discover that sooner than later.
Yeah, we got a comment from Damasta saying,
haha, sounds like my son, Evan.
Yeah, and it's, I like, I get it.
And especially different cultures, too, you know?
Some cultures are much more traditional
and saying no is a lot harder
and you're supposed to respect your, you know,
your parents, you're supposed to respect
the older generation, I get it.
But at some point, you may need to say,
listen, my culture doesn't work for me 100% of the time.
I need to go out and do my thing.
And that's courage.
The weak thing to do is to not admit who you are
and not follow what you're interested in,
at least in my opinion.
So, that's what I think.
Awesome.
And can you just remind me real quickly
of that great story of the Sony CEO?
Because he, like, that's about as much
of a cultural having to go against culture, right?
Sure.
Yeah, Akio Morita, the founder of Sony,
was 11 generations of sake brewers in Japan.
And, oh, I guess we're not doing the dragon.
And just, you know, Japanese culture is, you know,
one of the most traditional cultures in the world.
And he was expected, as the oldest son,
to go in and have to take over the business.
And he decided that he didn't want
to take over the business.
And instead, he would go start a startup company,
where in Japan, having a startup business
is not done a lot.
Startup culture isn't there, because it's too risky.
It's a very conservative culture.
But he said that he wanted to go and do it.
And I'm not going to go into the family business.
And his parents were disappointed.
You know, 11 generations of legacy.
Chase.
That's a lot of pressure, but he bet on himself.
And he didn't let the culture hold him back
from doing something that he wanted to do.
And it's not purposely going out
and being disrespectful, right?
It's not saying I'm doing this because I hate my culture,
or because I hate my parents, or whatever.
Like, your work should never be out of hate or anger.
Your work is doing something that you feel is important
and the right thing to do.
And hopefully it doesn't hurt others.
Hopefully you're helping people,
but not hurting people in the process too,
as much as possible.
So yeah.
I can read that.
It's a great story.
Great story.
And you know, I'll just add this last little thing,
because you're telling that story just reminded me.
One thing that is a step ahead for Israel and for Israelis
is, whereas Japan was not a startup nation,
Israel is, there's actually an entire New York Times
bestselling book called Startup Nation.
And it's the story of Israel's economic miracle.
And it talks all about how Israel,
this is just from the back of the book,
how Israel with only 7.1 million people,
no natural resources, enemies on every border,
and in a constant state of war,
produce more startup companies than Japan, India, Korea,
Canada, sorry, and the UK.
Drawing on examples from the country's foremost
inventors and investors.
So that might be a inspirational book for Sophie,
because you are living in a country that embraces
the startup and embraces entrepreneurs,
and is clearly a place that you can be successful.
So that might be a, it's called Startup Nation
by Dan Sinor and Saul Singer.
Cool.
Well, this is a long game.
This is a long game.
We just can't finish it.
We're getting, we've gotten close a couple of times,
but it's good, lets us answer some more questions.
Okay.
Next question comes from Yervontes.
Yervontes says,
my business partner and I have managed to create
a mobile game app for a celebrity.
And they have the opportunity to be bought,
and they wanted to know what are our options
for selling this game?
How much do we ask for?
Is it realistic to keep some of the rights,
and still get something up front?
If we sell it out right, how much do we ask for?
Kind of a lot of questions.
I can take them one at a time again.
So they have an app.
It's an app that's specifically for celebrity.
Like for example, you know how they have
the Kim Kardashian apps that are just made
around a particular celebrity.
They have the opportunity to be bought and wanna know
what are the options for selling this game?
How do we ask for?
Okay, let's just start with that.
So what are the options for selling this game?
Now, this area of selling and pricing
and all of those things, I'm gonna,
I don't wanna defer to you Evan
without providing some value.
All I know is that I don't have a lot of experience
in this particular world, but what I will say
is there's some great material on the channel
specifically for working with investors
and working with all of the things
that are around being bought as a company.
And so I would say definitely look on Evan's channel
for anything around apps and there's plenty of videos
on apps and plenty of videos on this information.
So I guess I just point you there.
We won, hey.
Hey.
Good times.
I was confused whether he already had a buyer lined up
or he was looking to sell.
That was the only question I had there.
Yeah, he has someone already who's willing to buy.
Got it.
So you can look at what apps have sold for in the past.
It's a tricky kind of market.
Typically when you're looking at investing,
it's, wait, sorry, acquisitions,
it's somewhere around one times revenue
unless it's a strategic buy.
So I don't know how much you're making from it
or what your growth curves looks like.
They may offer more.
And it's also thinking, do you want to sell?
Like every deal is its own deal.
Everything can potentially work.
How much is it important to you?
Like is it important for you to have a piece
of the ongoing pie?
Do you want to still be involved in the company?
Then if you're not involved and you own a percentage,
do you want to trust these guys
that they're going to pay you all the time
and do the right thing by the business, right?
Don't get greedy.
Greedy, what's the expression?
There's an expression in the venture capital world
about pigs going to slaughter.
I forget what it is.
It's like other animals are okay,
but pigs go to slaughter because you get greedy.
Do what you think is a fair deal.
And you can throw out options on the table
and see what they want to do.
You can see what offer they've already given you.
There's no one set price.
Some guy may pay you 10 times revenue
because he just needs to have what you have.
Or you may think that your future growth is so great
that what you're doing now,
I don't want to sell my company to Facebook yet.
Facebook wanted to buy, well they bought Instagram,
but they wanted to buy Snapchat.
Okay, well we don't want to sell.
We're on our growth curve.
We don't want to sell right now.
So do you have that kind of confidence in your business
to keep it going?
When I sold my first business, I didn't want to sell it.
My partners wanted to sell it as part of their goal
to move to California too.
And so I'm not going to hold back their life goal
to do that.
There's no set rule.
The most important thing for you to figure out
is all of those options that you're thinking about,
how do you balance them yourself?
How important is the ongoing piece versus the upfront cash
versus you're having a role or not in the business?
Do you have other ideas that you want to jump to
and this is a great way for you to get out
and test those new ideas?
Do you love your business so much
that you still see massive growth ahead
and you want to,
like the value that they're offering you isn't enough yet
and if you stick around for the two years
and keep making new apps, that's going to be your home.
You need to balance the priorities
and then figure out what your walk away price is.
And if you don't get the deal here,
you'll get the next deal.
Like the more you keep building up awareness
and attention and credibility in the industry,
the more people will just pay more attention to you
and the more opportunities you'll have
to work with celebrities and to get bought by somebody.
The best thing you can do to get noticed
is keep doing great work.
And if you understand, like it's just like anything else.
You want to go get a job?
Well, how important is the money you're making
versus the flexibility you get
versus the boss you're working with
versus the work that you're actually going to be doing
versus career advancement opportunities?
How do you balance that?
I don't know, there's a lot, like to you personally,
there's a lot of different ways to go about doing it.
It's figuring out for yourself
what's the highest priority for you.
I think we kind of answered all those questions
and won there.
Yeah, you're right.
I think you touched the wall.
It's really amazing.
And the quote you were talking about
with pigs get fat, hogs get slaughtered.
Pigs get fat, hogs get slaughtered.
I think it was something else.
Oh, is that not it?
No, no, it's something about pigs go to slaughter
or something else.
I figure what it is.
Oh, okay.
Anyway, which is don't be greedy.
Don't be greedy.
Make a fair deal.
Make something that makes sense for you
and where you're at in your life and where you want to go.
Greed kills deals.
Anyway, I got the best score in the game.
I got the best score on my team somehow.
I don't know how that happened, but.
But we won and yeah, good game.
Amazing.
So thank you guys so much for joining in.
Thank you Rishy for the awesome advice.
Any parting words?
No, Evan, just a cup of gratitude to you
for having me on today.
Thanks for everything.
I love it.
Thank you guys for watching.
Thank you for all the questions.
We'll see you back tomorrow morning
for 9 a.m. gratitude session,
9 10 a.m. Eastern League of Legends business Q&A.
And if you guys are sticking around later on today,
bunch of fun hangouts coming out.
Thank you guys.
Continue to believe or whatever your one word is.
And I'll see you soon.